the disparity and quality going from
Secret Invasion to Loki season 2 gave me
insane Whiplash on one hand we have a
terribly executed mess that had a crisis
behind the scenes and then on the other
we have a Triumph in storytelling that
tells a singular and spectacular vision
for a lovable character because that's
why Loki works so well over so many of
these other projects it has a deeply
engaging story that has a thoroughly
evolving main character Loki at the
start of the show until the end of
season 2 are practically opposite
characters and that kind of Journey
written in a compelling manner is
amazing this is going into what I think
is the best aspect of Loki season 2
which is Eric Martin's writing of
characters their Journeys and their
internal conflicts everyone on the
roster besides maybe one or two
characters have fully fleshed out arcs
with tangible motivations that make them
riveting and likable characters this is
what I would identify as Marvel's major
issue in that most character work has
taken a backseat as they prioritize
screen time in other areas recent
examples being Ant-Man quamania where
Scott and Cassie's relationship feels
very shallow and in the Marvels Carol
danver's primary internal conflict is
wholly underdeveloped then when you look
at Marvel's recent great movies like
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 and no way
home they tell engrossing stories that
are primarily driven by their ever
evolving characters Loki season 2 I
think Falls right into that category of
greatness because of how excellent its
character work is Loki's villain to Hero
Arc is a really hard thing to pull off
because it requires a complex dive into
the psyche of his character he goes from
someone who desperately tried to grasp
by control and purpose in his life
through any form of evil means all the
way to someone who only accepts power
out of sheer necessity of doing the
right thing and since this was done in a
show setting it gave the creators enough
time to fully explore this Rich
character Arc to its full potential we
actually have long and intriguing
dialogue scenes that are imbued with
important Revelations for our characters
like most dialogue scenes between two
characters generally lead to one of them
changing immensely examples being Loki
sparking the interest of what Mobius is
life was like outside of the TVA Loki's
talk with Sylvie in which she learns
that purely destroying something won't
solve problems and mobus driving in the
final nail to Loki's Arc in that one's
purpose is primarily burden over glory
and the burden is inevitable delivering
Loki's final Revelation in that he has
to become a time God and be burdened
with taking care of the entire
Multiverse a truly selfless act these
are just a few examples but every
episode is packed full of these
incredible dialog scenes now some are
obviously better than others and I'll
get into what I think are some of the
show's faults towards the latter half of
the video but the batting average is
still really high so much to the point
that it's admirable that primarily
character and dialog driven scenes carry
the show so much like looking at any
other Marvel show they generally have to
interject some kind of artificial action
to make the episode more exciting
however Loki doesn't need to do this
because of how high quality the drama is
in the show easily the best and most
refreshing climax in any Marvel show is
the showdown between he who remains and
Loki and Sylvie there's no crazy
spectacle or action setpiece to
entertain the audience and it's purely
dialogue and Loki season 2 somehow
elevates it and adds an additional layer
onto that finale from the first season I
honestly was kind of skeptical going
into the finale of Loki season 2 but it
far far away exceeded my expectations
the second finale confrontation with he
who remains really reminds me of the
final showdown between Sherlock Holmes
and mor Ari in that movie they're
playing these complex mind games where
they are constantly countering each
other and with the season 2 finale it
reveals he who remains his true plan and
that he knew looki would end up coming
back to stop Sylvie because of the Looms
fail safe and destroying all of time it
actually makes he who remains a more
evil character because it seems like he
did this out of pure boredom he knew the
out come would inevitably end the way it
would and he's doing this to torture
Loki and that he now has to kill someone
he cares about to save all of time
however like in Sherlock Holmes this
action made by the villain that comes
across as seemingly being a Checkmate
can actually be countered by our hero
this is the kind of writing that is
outstanding in which the viewer doesn't
know a logical way in overcoming the
conflict and the hero has to come up
with something that is clever for Loki
his solution to he who remains his
conundrum isn't just a clever solution
but it's also an integral step for Loki
in finishing his character Arc it
ironically acts as a layup of sorts for
Loki in finding his glorious purpose and
finishing his ultimate Redemption Arc
overcoming conflict is one thing but if
he can also make it expertly tie into
the main character's Arc then that's
great writing which is what Eric Martin
achieves here along with the Monumental
task of creating an hour worth of
riveting dialogue which is essentially
what the ending is it just requires a
lot more skill and Artistry to write
something of this caliber over something
like the W division finale which feels
significantly more convoluted and messy
narratively and I'm being generous
bringing that up as a comparison because
that's one of the better ones also for
the season 2 finale I love how they
essentially turned half of the episode
into Groundhog's Day which is one of my
favorite movies but applied it to a
hardcore science fiction setting seeing
Loki Ramis head into a wall trying to
overcome this mind-boggling conflict was
incredibly engrossing it would have been
nice if the finale was longer because I
I feel like the riters downplayed the
mental impact of doing the same thing
over and over for centuries but it was
still well executed maybe Loki is more
resilient to Long stretches of time
because he is a God after all so Loki's
character Arc is obviously outstanding
and the other two main Side characters
being Mobius and Sylvie are also great
of course Mobius and Loki's Dynamic is
still very endearing and the writers
lean into that even more for season 2 at
times it did feel a little forc an
example being mob leaving during a fight
scene to go find a bike with two seats
for him and Loki while in other moments
it felt more natural as long as the
writers weren't going out of their way
for any Shenanigans I felt like it was
fine but for Mobius overall I think it
was pretty genius in that the writers
were able to Showcase his entire life on
the timeline while also building Loki's
character in overcoming time slipping it
was very efficient and offered a
significant amount of value for Mobius
as a character as we got to witness his
entire backstory and the same thing
applies for other minor Side characters
like up until episode 5 I was kind of
sad that kihi Kwan's character Obie was
basically just a character that rattled
off complicated Exposition so the hope
is that after you prune yourself the
extractor will pull you into the present
of
course yeah but episode 5 flushes him
out and makes him more understandable as
a character and not just a vessel to
explain different mechanics within the
world because he's honestly just a
downgraded version from his character
and everything everywhere all at once
however I think episode epode 5 luckily
redeems him Sylvia I think has a good
continuation and her Arc of slowly
diffusing from a destruction mentality
was really well done and explored her
final scene with Loki was heartfelt and
perfectly punctuates the ending of her
Arc and aiding Loki and realizing that
destroying something is okay if you
replace it with something better now for
the last character I'll address that I
don't think was very well done was run
Slayer it feels like her villain Arc was
nowhere near as complex as the other
characters in the show because she
essentially just wants power and to
control the TVA even though she's
literally causing the tva's downfall by
delaying Mobius and Loki and fixing the
loom I know she doesn't trust them but
it feels like a contradiction in that
she wants to restore the TVA to its
former glory while also being the one
that's causing its downfall I guess
there is some irony there even though it
doesn't feel very logical from a
character point of view outside of her
lust for power there's really nothing
else about her to make her fascinating
the Revelation about her mind being
wiped I thought was a good twist for the
character but it again only feeds into
that lust for power so if anything it
kind of feels like Ren Slayer was used
as a roadblock conflict and drawing out
the story until the loom explodes
because without her the show would be
much shorter which this is fine I just
wish she was more compelling her state
in the show was pretty underwhelming
considering how much screen time she had
and especially how abrupt her ending was
the writers were kind of like oh yeah
and by the way Ren Slayer dies after
being sent to the void that's it then
her and miss min's lust towards Victor
timley was very odd and offputting to
the point that it was not needed at all
so even though run Slayer was partially
lacking I think Loki season 2's
characters were still outstanding all
around another aspect that goes hand
inhand with the characters is the acting
out of the entire MCU I think Tom Heston
is easily the best actor the amount of
range and raw emotion that is constantly
required for the character in every
scene is flooring it obviously helps
that the writing allows this but there
are so many beautiful close-ups of Loki
throughout the season in which he puts
you into a trance with his amazing
acting Tom hson has a Mastery
understanding of everything whether it
be subtlety gravitas Charisma pacing
great delivery of lines and Nails Sara
with ease he's literally a Flawless
actor and it's rare to be this
consistently floored I know that acting
awards for the Emmys is extremely
crowded from how many great shows are
running but it would honestly feel like
a snub if Tom hson doesn't get a Best
lead actor nomination unfortunately
though I feel like the voters will
automatically look past this show just
because of the Marvel Brand not being
what it used to be without Tom hson the
show would be practically nothing and he
perfectly sells the anguish and turmoil
Loki as a character is constantly going
through then other standouts I would say
are definitely Jonathan majors and
Sophia Martino I know the controversy
around Jonathan major is bad but that
doesn't take away from the fact that he
did a great job in season 2 at first I
found Victor timley to be kind of
annoying but his whole Ness quickly grew
on me and I loved how Jonathan got to
revisit he who remains again Sophia
Martino like Tom Heston delivers deeply
emotional moments with ease and they
always make a great pairing it's just a
little unfortunate she wasn't as heavily
featured in season 2 but that's fine
since that's what made sense for the
story then other actors who weren't as
prominent in the story still did a great
job one of my favorite examples is the
scene where all the prisoners get killed
and the filmmakers decide to only show
the reactions of both one me and Raphael
who perfectly mirror the horror they're
witnessing now I'll go into one more
great aspect about Loki season 2 before
going into some faults I had with the
season and the last great thing I want
to dive into is the production value of
the show Loki easily blows every other
MCU production out of the water because
this is the only show that actually
feels like a show they're constructing
numerous real sets that are reused
instead of constantly going to random
locations to film scenes that are in
turn in doll locations because they're
only used once building these sets also
probably saves them quite a bit of money
so that they can then spend it on making
the CGI look great because throughout
the show it looked pretty spectacular
and I especially love the spaghetti
unraveling of people being erased from
time it visually looked cool and was
creative the only CGI moment that was
very odd was actually the very beginning
of season 2 where looki jumps off of the
TVA Tower and lands into a flying car
the shot immediately scared me from how
rough it looked as if it beginner and
blender made it I would say that the
moment right after this where a
practical car crashes into a real set
redeems the janky looking shots but yeah
the overall visual look of the show is
of such a high quality and has a strong
visual identity because of its unique
and exotic locations similar obviously
to season 1 even though I would argue
that season 1 visually was more
memorable than season 2 there is an
entirely different cinematographer and
different directors that in turn make
the show feel different visually but I
saw still think it looks good I don't
think the vast majority of viewers will
notice a major shift although to me the
first season looked a bit more dramatic
in terms of its lighting for different
scenes while season 2 feels more loose
and is directed and shot with an
ensemble of characters taken into
account so going into what I think is
the main fault of the season and I know
this video is titled as being a Triumph
of a show but I don't think season 2 is
a Flawless 10 out of 10 the first half
of the season in comparison to the
latter half I think is weaker and there
are a few reasons for this firstly the
plot of episodes 2 and three were
primarily subplots that were there to
buy time until the ending of the show
now you may immediately disagree with
that assessment so let me explain in
episode 2 Loki and milia spent half of
the episode questioning Brad about where
Sylvie is and also uncover a sudden
conflict that there are loyalist killing
branching timelines there's not a lot of
setup for this development especially
for Brad's character it feels as though
we skipped over an episode as this
random background character becomes an
integral centerpiece out of nowhere so
you spend half the time confused as if
you miss something and why we're
spending so much time with him then
after this conflict is resolved the
leader of these loyalists becomes
irrelevant within the story as Ren
Slayer comes in to kill her now is the
writing for these scenes bad by any
means absolutely not it just doesn't
feel like an efficient usage of time in
terms of Storytelling there is some
importance for this episode in that it
ropes silly back into the narrative
they're able to find friend Slayer and
establishes Brad as a character but I
can't help but escape the feeling that
we're just spending time on a subplot
for this episode and the same thing
applies for episode 3 I know Victor
timley is a pretty important character
but the writers only make him that way
because they randomly require the
Creator's Aura to unlock the blast doors
the writers only do this to give Victor
timely importance within the narrative
because besides that he doesn't really
offer anything to the story he helps out
with some scientific problem solving but
that's kind kind of a minor point that
you can just write to have Obie think of
so for episode 3 we essentially have
this entire artificial side quest to get
a character who has random importance
because the writers W it to happen now
again the time spent here in the show
doesn't mean it was bad just in
comparison to the latter half of season
2 which features a clean and efficient
narrative the first half feels inferior
the writers still include solid
character developments and overall
well-written scenes so I think it
partially alleviates this fault
also I think it could have been a
narrative upgrade if they had Mobius be
the one who goes out on the catwalk in
episodes 4 and six instead of Victor
Mobius is loss at the end of episode 4
would be much more of a motivator for
Loki because Mobius is like his best
friend along with having much higher
Stakes because we as an audience care
more about Mobius rather than a
character who just showed up that and
imagine how much of a gut punch the
ending to episode 4 would be if we
thought Mobius died so in an overall
sense I don't think Victor timely
ultimately added a lot to the story and
could have been removed from it without
much loss being felt and I feel like I
have to keep bringing this up in which
I'm not knocking the quality of episodes
2 and 3 and just the relevance and
importance to the main plots since there
are only six episodes within the season
spending time in suppl has felt even
more because the story is already short
this in comparison to season 1 where
every episode was extremely productive
and progressing the main story starts to
feel like a star contrast which Speaking
of of this comparison I think season 1
of Loki is a bit stronger because of the
fact that each episode thoroughly
engages you from a plot perspective what
I mean by this is that every episode
hooks you with a captivating mystery as
we keep going further down this alluring
rapid hole of a story like figuring out
what the TVA is finding out that we're
hunting a variant who's a Loki the Loki
variant being a girl and her actually
being kind of a protagonist the
timekeepers being fake overcoming the
void in Goliath and meeting he who
remains in getting answers to all of our
questions season 1 is utterly packed to
the brim with an engaging and fun plot
that it kind of makes season 2 seem
underwhelming in comparison where in
season 2 the plot is basically just
trying to fix the loom with a couple
subplots interjected to make the season
longer I wouldn't say this is very bad
because the narrative still hits an
absolute high point for the finale just
it's kind of a shame that the first half
of the Season doesn't really match the
high quality of the second half of the
season so that's really the only main
flaw I had with season 2 that brought it
down slightly and there were also
occasionally some weird moments in terms
of writing like The Surreal scene where
Victor insists upon going to get a cup
of coffee where Brad kills Soap and
kidnaps Victor that was honestly one of
the weirdest and most contrived scenes
in the entire show that it felt jarring
watching that scene in An otherwise
great episode then another contrived
moment that stood out to me was Sylvie
sending Ren Slayer to the end of time
instead of killing her like she didn't
even take her temp pad and I thought she
was intending her being stuck there as
if the Fate being worse than death but
yeah every now and then the writing
falters and the tone can feel a bit
weird at times like Victor's chasing in
episode 3 but I think the average
quality of season 2 is high enough to
the point that these sudden quality
shifts aren't a major deal that and the
ending is so amazing that you can
forgive some of the show's faults so
overall Loki season 2 even though I'd
say is a minor downgrade from season 1
is still far and a way better than
basically anything Marvel has produced
in the last few years this is the bar of
quality that I wish the MCU can
regularly operate in it's kind of
unfortunate that Disney is also
releasing the Marvels at the same time
as the finale of Loki season 2 so
they're essentially overshadowing
something they made that's great with
something that's bad that just seems
baffling to me that they would do that
but thank you for watching my letter box
patreon and Discord links are in the
description and I also just did a review
on the Marvels if you want to check that
out
too